und wir schauen in die USA dann ist es
eine wirklich schreckliche Gewaltwelle
die New York City gerade erfasst Gewalt
in der U-Bahn in der Subway 9 Morde die
Menschen in der Stadt die ihre Subway
lieben und brauchen die fahren jetzt mit
Angst
New York City die Stadt die niemals
schläft wird gerade von einer
verbrechenswelle überrollt besonders
brutal die Gewalt in der New Yorker
Subway der U-Bahn Raubüberfälle
Messerangriffe und Mord sorgen hier für
Angst und Schrecken Tatort Station East
southern Boulevard Sonntag 11:50 Uhr ein
26-jähriger wird von hinten auf die
Gleise der Linie 6 gestoßen eine
Videokamera hält die Sekunden vor der
Tat fest als der Täter sich dem Opfer
von hinten nähert diesmal gibt es jedoch
ein Wunder Passanten helfen dem Mann
zurück auf dem Bahnsteig er wird aber am
Bein verletzt die Polizei fahndet noch
nach dem Täter die New Yorker City
Subway ist das verkehrsrückrad der
Metropole 1300 Kilometer Streckenlänge
fast 500 einzelne Stationen und 5,5
Millionen tägliche Fahrten werden hier
absolviert doch zuletzt wird eben dieses
Verkehrs Rückgrat immer öfter zur
Todesfalle allein in diesem Jahr sind
neun Menschen bereits ums Leben gekommen
bei Vorfällen in der Sache viele auf die
Gleise geschubst Tatort Jackson highsold
Avenue Heriberto kintana betritt die
U-Bahn Station und kollidiert irrtümlich
mit einem anderen Mann dessen Handy auf
die Gleise fällt zwischen den Männern
kommt es zum lautstarken Streit Quintana
wird schließlich auf die Gleise
geschubst ein einfahrener Zug der Linie
F erfasst ihn der Täter ist in Polizei
Gewahrsam
Tatort Station one Hund Street in der
Bronx nach dem Verlassen eines Zuges der
Linie 4 kommt es am Bahnsteig zu einer
Messerstecherei der 38-Jährige Charles
Moore wird tödlich verwundet der Täter
wird noch von der Polizei gesucht Anfang
des Monats kam es hier zu einer
tödlichen messestecherei der Zug ist
eingefahren zwei Männer stiegen aus und
hier am Bahnsteig kam es eben zu dieser
Gewalttat und das war der zweite der
dritte vor von eigentlich innerhalb von
wenigen Tages alles Messerstechereien in
der New Yorker Subway eine dramatische
Lage
die New Yorker in Angst der Big Apple
überroll von einer Welle der Gewalt und
kein Ende in Sicht
die Reportage von unserem New York
Korrespondenten Herbert Bauer Nebel der
jetzt live bei uns ist ich grüße dich
Herbert also diese Stadt New York City
hat gerade ein Gewaltproblem ein
u-bahn-problem warum
es gibt zahlreiche Gründe dafür wie
gesagt die Zahlen sind dramatisch allein
neun Tote bereits in diesem Jahr seit
März 2020 sind es 22 tote davor musste
man eben 13 Jahre warten um auf eine
gleiche Opferzahl zu kommen die Gründe
wie gesagt sind vielfältig zum einen ist
es der die Verbreitung von Waffen die
hier überhand genommen ist so sieht es
jedenfalls der bürgermeister Eric Adams
dazu kommt allerdings auch eine
Strafrechtsreform hier in New York wo
viele Gewalttäter wieder freigelassen
werden gegen Kaution und insgesamt
natürlich ist es auch dieser wachsenden
verbrechenswelle in New York geschuldet
die eben seit der coronavirus-pandemie
hier wütet und natürlich besonders oft
kommt es zu diesen grässlichen Vorfällen
in der New Yorker Suppe wie gesagt es
ist das wichtigste Verkehrsmittel und in
New Yorker schauen sich jetzt hier jeden
Morgen jeden Tag jeden jeden Nachmittag
jeden Abend gegenseitig über die
Schulter wenn sie mit ihren Zügen nach
Hause fahren ganz kurz fährst du
angstfrei
oder sind diese neuen Morde jetzt auch
in deinem Alltag präsent
man hat so ein gewisses persönliches
Ritual man geht einfach nicht mehr knapp
an den Bahn an die Bahnsteigkante heran
viele Menschen warten bei den bei den
Stufen bei den Treppen die hinuntergehen
halten sich teilweise sogar an man spürt
wirklich dass man hier ein eine Angst
eine Angst sieht unter den Passagieren
und auch teilweise selbst ein mulmiges
Gefühl hat und sich ebenfalls ein wenig
über die Schulter schaut natürlich eine
Gewaltwelle in der New York City Subway
dazu unser new yorkerspondent Herbert
Bauer danke dir
[Musik]